Meiosis gives us the diversity that we
see in our everyday lives. It's a
special type of cell division found in
eukaryotes that sexually reproduce,
including plants, fungi and animals
like us.
Let's take human meiosis as an example,
a process that gives rise to our
gametes,
eggs and sperm.
Human gametes have one copy of each of
the 23 chromosomes, which is half the
number of most of our body cells.
For simplicity, we will only follow two
chromosomes through meiosis. When the
egg and spoon fuse, they produce a
fertilized cell, which has 46
chromosomes, one copy from your mother
and one from your father.
So how do gametes end up with only half
the number of chromosomes? That's where
meiosis comes in. So how does meiosis
work? Meiosis starts with a cell that
contains two copies of every chromosome.
Each copy of the chromosome is
replicated to double the number of
chromosomes.
Each identical copy is called a
chromatid.
The two identical purple chromatids
pair up with the two identical yellow
chromatids, and this is where swapping
of DNA occurs, in a crossing over
process called recombination.
It's the first step in which genetic
diversity is introduced.
After crossing over, the pairs of
chromatids line up along the center of
the cell.
The pairs are then pulled to opposite
ends of the cell by a protein machine
called the spindle. This is the second
step where diversity is introduced, as
it is random whether the mother or the
father pair of chromatids goes to one
end of the cell or the other.
Immediately following this first
division, there is a second division
without any DNA replication. This
division reduces the number of each
chromosome from two, diploid, to one,
haploid. Thus,
when the gametes, the sperm and the
egg, fuse together, we restore the
normal number of chromosomes for the
next generation.
Can you now see how meiosis gives us
the diversity that we see in our
everyday lives? It's the reason you
don't look identical to your mom or
your dad. Without meiosis, we would all
be clones of each other.